All right. Hey, everyone. Welcome back.
Um, this is, people can hear me okay? All right.
So if as usual,
you can take a second to enter your,
uh, SU ID so we know who's here.
Um, so today's lecture will be a Choose Your Own Adventure lecture, um.
So I think, you know,
by now you've learned a lot about the, um,
technical aspects of building learning algorithms and then,
in the third course, uh,
in the third set of modules,
you saw some of the principles for
debugging Learning Algorithms and how best to use these tools,
um, in order to be efficient in how you build a machine learning application.
What I want to do today is a step through with you,
a moderately complicated machine learning application,
and, um, throughout all of today's lecture,
I'm gonna, you know,
step you through a scenario and then ask you to kind of choose your own adventure.
Because if you have to work on this project,
what are you gonna do, right?
Um, and to give you more of that practice in the next, um,
what, hour and a bit that we have, uh,
on thinking through machine learning strategy, um.
And you know I've,
I've seen in so many projects, uh, there are,
there are sometimes things that
a less strategically sophisticated team will take a year to do,
but if you're actually very strategic and very
sophisticated in deciding what you will do next, right,
how to drive a project forward,
I've seen many times that what a different team will take to do,
maybe you could do it in a month or two, right.
And, you know, if you're trying to, um,
I don't know, write a research paper, or build a business, or build a product,
the, the, the ability to drive
a machine learning project quickly gives you a huge advantage and just,
you know, you're making much more efficient use of your life as well, right.
Um, so, in, for today I'd like to,
er, er, I'm gonna pose a scenario,
pose a machine learning application and say,
all right, I mean you are the CEO of this project, what are you going to do next?
So, but I'd like to have today's meeting be quite interactive as well.
So, can I get people to sit in groups of two,
and ideally three or so,
maybe plus minus one and
try to sit next to someone that you don't work with all the time.
Er, so, so, if you're sitting,
sitting next to your best friend,
I'm glad your best friend is in the class with you,
but go sit with someone else because I think,
um- I've done this multiple times and the discussion's
actually richer if you talk to someone that you don't know super well.
So actually take a second,
introduce yourself and, and, and, and just greet your neighbor, I guess.
So, the example I wanna go through today is actually
a continuation of the example I described briefly,
uh, uh, in the last lecture I taught, uh,
Building a Speech Recognition System, right.
So, remember I briefly motivated this trigger word,
wake word or trigger word detection system last time where,
you know, uh, right.
I, I, I, I, I actually have both an Amazon Echo and a Google Home, uh,
but you know, it's it's a lot of work to
configure these things to turn on and off the light bulbs,
um, and so if you can build a chip,
uh, to sell to say a lamp maker,
to recognize uh, phrases like,
you know- let's say we call the lamp Robert, right, um.
Then you can recognize phases like Robert, turn on, right?
Robert turn off, and you have a little switch to give this thing different names,
you can call it Robert, or,
or Rainier or Alice or something.
So you can also have Rainier,
turn on, Rainier, turn off.
Just give, give your a lamp a name and just say Hey,
Robert, turn on, right?
So, rather than detecting different names and turn on and turn off,
I'm just gonna focus on- just for the technical discussion,
I'm just going to focus on the phrase Robert turn on, er,
but it's kind of the same problem we need to solve like,
four times to give it two names or to turn on and turn off.
So, I'm gonna abbreviate Robert turn on as RTO, right,
so if you wanna call your name Robert and,
um, tell your lamp to turn on, um.
I think I was inspired by one Isaac Asimov,
wrote these um, robotic novel series and,
and all his robots' name started with R. So,
maybe R is Robot turn on, um.
And so, uh, let's see.
So, let's say that, um,
you are the new CEO of a small startup with,
you know, three persons, uh,
and your goal is to build an, um,
is to build a circuit or actually,
your goal is to build a learning algorithm, um,
that can recognize this phrase,
Robert turn on, er,
so that when someone, you know,
buys this lamp and they say Robert turn on,
then the lamp can turn on, right?
And just focusing on the task of building, and then,
then, you know, to,
to be CEO of the startup, it means you need to do a lot of things, right?
You need to figure out how to do the embedded circuitry,
you figure out who are the lamp makers, etc.
So there's all that stuff, but for today,
let's just focus on the machine learning aspect of it, um.
And so my first question to you is very open-ended,
is- but and this is the life of a CEO, right?
You wake up one day and you've just got to decide what to do, um.
But so my first question to you is the open-ended question is,
you're the CEO, uh,
you're gonna shop at work uh, you know,
tomorrow in your startup office and you want to build
a learning algorithm to detect the phrase Robert turn on for this application, right?
So, um, so my question is,
what are you gonna do, right?
So take a, take a minute to,
uh, answer that by yourself first.
Uh, don't, don't discuss with your neighbor yet,
but you know, you're gonna shop in your office and,
and then you're gonna start working on
these engineering problems of building a neural network to do this so,
uh, and, and do this as yourself, right?
Don't, don't, don't pretend the- yeah, this hypothetical whatever,
er, er, er, er, startup CEO with $10 billion to spend or whatever.
Just do it. Just say yeah,
I- but I don't think this is a terrible startup idea.
I, I, I, I, this is not the best idea but I think this could work.
So you're actually welcome to do this.
But let's say you decide to do this and you go
into your office tomorrow, right, what do you do, right?
Why don't you take, um,
why don't you take let's say two minutes to enter an answer,
then we can, then we can discuss.
[NOISE] In fact, I think,
uh, yeah, yes, I,
one thing I really like about the answer was actually
the read exist- read existing literature part, right, um.
In fact when you start a new project, um, uh,
uh, and I think, um,
uh, when you start doing a new project like that,
assuming you've not worked with trigger word detection before, you know,
reading research papers or reading code on GitHub, or reading blog posts on
this problem is actually a very good way to quickly level up your knowledge, um.
And I think that, you know it, it, it turns out that,
uh, in terms of your,
uh, exploration strategy, right, um,
I want to describe to you how I read research papers, um,
uh, which is- so this is, um,
not a good way to review the literature which is if
the x-axis is time and the vertical axis is research papers,
what some people will do is find the first research paper and read that until it's done.
And then go and find a second research paper and read that until it's done,
and then go and find
the third research paper and this- because this is a very sequential way
of reading research papers and I find
that the more strategic way to to go through these resources,
everything ranging from blog posts, um,
lots of good Medium articles that explain things,
right, uh, research papers,
um, right, GitHub.
Is if you use a parallel exploration process where-
This, this is actually what it feels like when I'm doing research on the web.
I'm trying to learn about a new field I'm not that experienced in.
Right, so I've just done a lot of work on trigger word detection.
But if I hadn't worked on this before,
then I would probably find you know, three papers.
So again x-axis is time and vertical axis as different papers.
And um, you know read a few papers,
kind of in parallel at a surface level and skim them.
And based on that, you might decide to read that one in greater detail,
and then to add other papers that you start skimming
and maybe find another one that you want to read in great detail,
and then to gradually add new papers to
your reading list and read some to completion and some not to completion.
Um, you, I, I was actually chatting with um, ah, ah,
one of my friends, uh,
a for- former student at Berkeley,
who mentioned that he was wanting to learn about a new topic.
And he, he was,
he told me he's compiling a reading list of 200 research papers that
he wanted to read. That sounds like a lot.
You rarely read 200 papers.
But I think if you read 10 papers,
you have a basic understanding.
If you read 50, you have a pretty decent understanding.
If you read like 100,
I think you have a very good understanding, uh, uh,
of, of, of a few but often this is [NOISE] time well spent. I guess.
Um and ah, some other tips, again this is,
I'm- I'm really thinking if you really are
a CEO of this startup and this is what you wanna do,
what advice would I give you?
Um, ah, ah when you're reading papers ah,
other thing to realize,
one is that uh,
some papers don't make sense.
Right. And this fine.
Uh, uh, even I read some papers I would just go nope.
I don't think that makes sense.
Uh, and, and it's not that uncommon for us to uh,
find papers from a decade ago and we learned that half of it was great
and the other half of it you know
was really talking about things that were not that important.
Right, so it's okay.
Uh, uh, authors you know,
usually papers are technically accurate but often what they thought was
important like maybe an author thought
that using batch number was really important for this problem.
But it just turns out not to be the case.
That, that happens a lot.
That happens sometimes.
[NOISE] Um, and I think the other tactic that I see
Stanford students sometimes not use enough is uh,
talking to experts including contacting the authors.
So when I read a paper [NOISE] um, uh,
I don't, I don't bother the authors
unless I've actually like tried to figure it out myself.
Right. But if you actually spend some time trying to understand
the paper and if it really doesn't make sense to you uh,
uh, uh, it's, it's,
it's okay to email the authors and see if they respond.
And [NOISE] and people are busy.
Maybe there's a 50 percent chance of respond.
And that's okay because it takes you five minutes
to write an email and there's a 50 percent chance to get back to you.
That could be time pretty well spent.
Uh, uh, but, but don't, don't,
don't bother people unless you've tried to do your own work.
I, I usually get a lot of emails from you know high-school students tha- that do
not feel like they've done their own work an- and I just write, and then yes.
So just don't, don't,
don't bother people unless you've actually tried to do your own work.
[LAUGHTER] Um [NOISE] cool.
So, after um, [NOISE] looking at the literature ah,
and having a base maybe downloading
an open source implementation or getting a sense of the avenue you wanna try.
Oh and it, it turns out the,
the trigger word detection literature is actually
one literature where there isn't consensus on.
This is a good algorithm, this a bad algorithm.
Right. Despite all the trigger word, wake word
detection systems that you know some of you may use already uh,
there, there, there isn't actually consensus in the,
in, in, in the research for me today on like,
this is the best avenue to try.
Um, but so let's say that um, you've read some papers,
downloaded some open-source implementations and now
you want to start training your first system.
Right. And last time we talked about this we talked a little bit
about how much time you will spend to collect data,
and, and you know, we said you sp- spend a small amount of time.
Spend like a day, or maybe two days at most.
So collect your first data sets and start training up a model.
Um, but my next question to you is what data would you collect?
Right. Um, in particular what train dev test data
[NOISE] would you collect?
So you've decided on an initial neural network architecture and you
want to [NOISE] train something to recognize this phrase, Robert turn on.
Uh, I think this uh, probably I don't think it's possible to download the data set.
I don't think anyone has collected a data set
with the words Robert turn on and posted it on the Internet.
So you have to collect your own data for
this particular trigger phrase that you wanna use.
But um, you know as CEO of this startup trying to build a neural net to
detect the phrase "Robert turn on," um what data do you collect?
Right. So why don't you take,
why don't you again, take on um,
let's say three minutes to write an answer to this.
Yeah. I think this is an interesting one.
Um, Robert turn on over and over and then data augmentation.
[NOISE] Um, data augmentation is one of those techniques that um,
uh, is a way to reduce
the variance in your learning algorithm because you're generating more data.
And ah, having worked on this problem I happen to know data augmentation works uh,
is very useful for this problem.
But if you didn't already know that fact this is
one of the things I would probably not do right away,
because I would train a quick and dirty system validate that you really
have a high variance problem before investing the effort into data augmentation.
So data augment is one of those techniques that so you know,
like it never hurts here or it rarely hurts,
usually helps but I don't bother to make that investment unless you have
collected the evidence that you actually have
a high variance problem and that this is actually a good use of your time.
Right.
Yeah. [NOISE] I think this,
this one actually, this is actually nice.
So um, uh, record everyone at startup saying, Robert turn on 100 times.
So rea- really nice thing about that.
You get it done really quickly.
Um, uh, when I'm working with teams um,
I actually think in terms of hours,
in terms of how long it take us to do something.
So this one you can probably do in like 30 minutes.
Right so you get your data set collected in 30 minutes and get going.
Uh, or, or, or you run around Stanford and just ask you know
friends or strangers to speak into your uh, uh, laptop microphone.
You could spend a few hours to get a much bigger data set than possibly at startup.
I probably do that. Probably I should go and collect
data in several hours rather than only spend 30 minutes.
But this is actually pretty interesting as well because it lets you
get it done really quickly. That makes sense?
Right. [NOISE] So um, yeah.
So let me actually uh, uh,
share some more concrete advice.
Right. And, and I think I should someti- sometime back um, to,
to prepare a homework problem that you'll see later in this course.
Ken and Eunice and I, we're actually you know building the system partially to,
to, to create a homework right, that, that,
that you'll see later in this course. So this is like a [NOISE].
Uh, this trigger word thing is
a nice learning example that we're using in a few points throughout this course.
Um, so here's one thing you can do.
Uh, and this, this is actually what's um,
[NOISE] what we did.
Right. Which is uh, collect [NOISE] um,
well simplifying a little bit um,
[NOISE] collect a hundred examples [NOISE] of uh,
uh, 10-second audio clips.
Right? And so, uh,
it turns out once you grab a hold of someone,
uh, and ask them to speak into your microphone, you know,
you can keep them for, um, three seconds
which is how long it takes to say, Robert turn on
or you can keep them for ten seconds which they're actually very
willing to spend the extra seven seconds with you.
Right? Um, but so if this is ten seconds of audio data, you know,
so this is ten seconds of audio, right, and,
and audio is just patterns of,
uh, little changes in air pressure.
Right. So, if you plot audio,
the reason it looks like this waveform.
It's just, uh, the,
the way you're hearing my voice is you know,
my voice or the speakers are creating very rapid changes in air pressure and
your ear measures those very rapid changes in
air pressure, interprets the sound and so a microphone, uh,
is a sensitive device for recording these very very high frequency changes in
air pressure and these plots that you see
in audio is just, what is the air pressure at different moments in time.
Right? But so given a, um,
uh, ten second clip like this.
If this is a three-second section,
where they said, Robert turn on,
then what you would like to do is to build a desk lamp say,
that can sit here and the lamp is turned off,
turned off, turn off,
turned off, turned off, turned off.
And at the moment they finish saying, Robert turn on, yeah, you turn it on.
So this is, uh, output label y really, right?.
And then, and then it's not detecting the phrase.
So- so what you want to do for the trigger word system is,
um, at you know,
pretty much the moment they finished saying Robert turn on, uh,
you once your learning algorithm to output a one, that's your target label y saying,
"Yeah, I just heard this trigger word."
Uh, and for all other times,
you wanted to output zero,
right? Cause- because, uh, and the one is when you
decide to turn on the lamp at that moment in time.
Right? So to collect the data set,
um, here's something you can do,
which is collect 100 audio clips,
of 10 seconds each.
And you know, when I'm prioritizing my work or my team's work,
I will really, you know,
look at these numbers and think okay,
let's say- let's say you actually if you are doing it.
Let's say you are running around Stanford and you want to collect 100 audio clips,
uh, uh, maybe 10 people,
10 clips per person or maybe 100 different people.
Um, I will actually estimate, you know,
if you go to Stanford cafeteria uh,
how long does it take to get one person?
You can probably get one person every minute or two,
if you go to a busy place on,
on like the Stanford cafeteria.
So you could probably get this done in like, uh,
100 to 200 minutes, like, two or three hours right?
It's not that bad. So you get this done quite quickly.
Um, and so and,
and let's say you collect 100 audio clips and actually for the,
for the, for the purposes of,
uh, today let's say,
you collect 100 audio clips to use for training,
25 for your dev set,
um, [NOISE] and zero for the test set.
Right. That's actually not that uncommon if you're building
a new product to just not have a test set because your goal is, uh,
to build something that convinces, you know,
just early prototyping phases of a project,
sometimes they don't bother with a test set.
If, if, it goes to publish a paper then
of course you need a rigorously collected test set.
But if you're just building a product,
then you don't need a rigorous evaluation sometimes you can
just get started without dealing with a test set, right?
So it's pretty easy to get started.
Um, and then.
[NOISE]
All right.
So taking that audio clip from above, um,
one thing you can do to turn this into a supervised learning problem, uh,
is to take- so the,
the phrase Robert turn on can be said in less than three seconds.
So let's say you take three seconds as the duration of audio.
Right? So we can do is, uh, clip out.
So let's say here was when Robert turn on was said.
So what you can do is, uh,
oh, right,  and the target label is zero, zero, zero,
zero, zero, zero, zero one,
zero, zero, zero, zero.
Um, what you can do is then clip out different audio clips of three seconds.
So here's one audio clip,
you can take that audio clip.
This is X and the target label is zero because,
because was Robert turn on was not said [NOISE].
Um, and you can take on- on this audio clip at different random, each clipped,
three second clip and that clip also has a target label 0.
Um, and you know,
for this one right?
Which is a three-second clip that can,
that-that, that ends at,
uh, on, the last part of the on sound you would have a target label of 1.
Right? So, and- and when- when you learn about sequence models, RNNs,
you learn a better method than this explicit clipping.
But for now let's say you take these,
um, audio clips and turn it into, uh,
three- so take a 10 second clip and by clipping
out ran- different windows you can take your,
um, let's say 100, uh- uh, clips.
And because for each ten second clip you can take different windows,
you could turn this into let say,
uh, 3,000 [NOISE] training examples.
Right? So here I took a ten second clip and - and [NOISE] show, you know,
took three different three second windows, but you take 30 three second windows,
then each 10 second audio clip becomes 30 examples.
And now, you've turned a problem into
a binary classification problem where you need to train a neural network
that inputs a three-second clip and labels it as either zero or one.
Right? This make sense?
And so this is an example of, uh,
the- the more complex, uh,
pipelines you might have,
if you're building a learning algorithm.
So take a continuous, you know,
audio detection problem and turn it into
a binary classification problem which you've
learned how to build various neural networks for.
Right? And again, when you learn about RNNs,
you learn about other ways to process sequence data or temporal data.
Okay. So, um, oh, go ahead.
[inaudible] uh is that manually getting the data?
[NOISE] Uh is this manually getting, yes, I would, yeah, actually,
if you have 100 examples, uh,
it's not that hard to just listen to it on your laptop or
some audio playing software to figure out when- when they finished saying,
uh, Robert turn on.
And then at that moment to put a one in the target label right?
Because this is really when you want the lamp to turn on, right?
Makes sense? Cool.
So, um, any other questions?
Actually, feel free to ask clarifying questions, yeah, go ahead.
I, I wonder if this is gonna cause a problem but  ones are too sparse.
Oh, sure, let me get back to that. Anything else? All right.
Is there a specific reason why you only train them on a few seconds instead of ten seconds, [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[NOISE] I see, yeah, why do we do three seconds, or four or five seconds
then there's another hyperparameter to contend. So I think.
uh, [NOISE] I don't know,
you have say it really slowly to take a few seconds is this, right?
This is Robert turn on.
And so again is this design choice?
[LAUGHTER] Um, yeah,  all right.
So, so, um, let's say you do this,
feed it to a supervised learning algorithm,
train a neural network, um,
and let's say that when you classify this,
ah, when, when you run this algorithm,
you end up with 99.5 percent accuracy [NOISE] right? Um,
uh, but you find that the algorithm has zero detections.
[NOISE]
Right? Um, and, and what I mean is that whatever audio you give it,
it just output zero all the time.
So the algorithm just says, nope,
I never heard the phrase "Robert turn on", you know.
So, so, uh, so, uh,
so, so my question to you is,
you know- and by the way,
the reason I'm going through these scenarios is,
um, I found that, uh,
a good way to gain good intuitions and,
and to become good at making these decisions,
is these are the decisions that a project leader, ri ght, or a tech leader or a CEO needs to make.
These are actually like pretty much exactly the decisions you need to make.
And I find that, um,
one of the ways to gain this type of experience is you,
you know, find a job with a good AI team and work with them for five years, right?
And then you actually live through this and you see what they do.
But instead of needing you to go and spend five years to see ten examples of this,
I'm trying to step you through maybe one example in, in one hour.
So, so instead of, uh, you know,
gaining this experience through work experience, which is great,
but takes many, many years [LAUGHTER] or many,
many months hoping to,
you know, let's just put you in the position of making these decisions.
You can learn from them much faster, right?
Um, so- and all the examples I'm giving are actually completely realistic, right?
They're either exactly or very similar to things I have seen in,
in actual, you know, very real projects.
So question is your learning algorithm gives this result,
95 percent accuracy, zero detections, what do you do?
Let me mention some of- some of the answers I really liked.
I think that, uh, um, you know,
I- when I think of building learning algorithms,
the process is often specify a dev set and/or test set that measure what you care about.
And then you don't always have to do it,
but it's good hygiene.
It's just- it is,
uh, sharpens the clarity of your thinking, right?
If you have a very clear specification of the problem.
And I think one insight out of this is that if your dev set is really out of whack, right?
Because it's so unbalanced,
that accuracy in your dev set doesn't translate to what you actually care about.
Because, you know, presumably,
this is 99.5 percent accurate on the dev set as well.
But this performance is terrible.
So it's doing great on a dev set,
on your accuracy metric, but giving you terrible performance.
So I think of it as good hygiene.
You know, this is kind of good sound practice, uh, to,
to just specify, make sure you at least have a dev set and
evaluation metric that corresponds more closely to what you care about.
So making the dev set more balanced, uh,
equal numbers of positive and negative would,
would be a good step toward that.
Um, and then I think,
um, uh, you could also,
um- there are a few people that talked about, um,
give the higher weights to the positive examples, right?
So, you know, um, uh,
one way to do this is to resample your training and your dev sets to make
them more proportionate in terms of
maybe closer to a balanced ratio positive negative examples.
That'd be okay. The other way to not do resampling,
we'd just give the positive examples a greater weight, right?
Um, I would probably resample.
Um, another thing you could do, um,
uh, you know, in the,
in the interests of, um, speed,
even if it's not the mathematically most,
most sound thing to do,
is to change the target labels to be a bunch of ones after that.
And this is a hack, this is not formally rigorous.
But if you've implemented the rest of this code already,
this might be a reasonable,
you know, a little bit hacky thing to do.
But this is- this, this, this might work well enough.
Right? I would- I might not- I don't know if I would want
to try to write an academic research paper with this method,
maybe you can get away with it.
But this little thing that I think if you tried to publish a paper with this,
academic reviewers might raise their eyebrows and say maybe,
you know, maybe this is okay.
But I think if you want something quick and dirty, that just works.
I think, uh, uh, labeling the ones,
changing a bunch of labels to be ones so that's,
say, a clip here, right?
Uh, that ends just a little bit after Robert turn on, that's still labeled one,
that'll be pretty reasonable.
But this will be saying that, uh,
for anywhere [NOISE] within maybe a 0.5 second period after Robert turn on finished,
it's okay to turn on the light anytime within that period.
That you kind of wanna be turning on the light.
Turning on the lamp, you know,
say within half a second, right, after Robert turn on is- has been said.
And this would be a not- this would be a way to just get more labels of ones in there.
All right, that makes sense? Yeah?
With like rebalancing your data sets with [inaudible] ,
how does that translate to when you deploy this,
you're not going to see Robert turn on as much, right?
Like one out of 1,000 might be reflected,
but what do we expect to see?
Yeah, yeah. Right. So, um,
I think that, uh- how do we put it?
Um, so if you actually- yes, so uh, this,
this is sort of a dev set and evaluation measure kind of question, right?
So, uh, one of the- a couple of the metrics that people often use,
uh, when actually working on this, is,
uh, when someone says Robert turn on,
what is the chance that it actually wakes up, or the lamp turns on?
And then the second is, if no one is saying anything to the lamp, you know,
how often does it randomly turn on by itself without you having said anything?
So those are the two metrics people actually use.
And, and sometimes you also
try to combine them in a single number evaluation metric or something.
Uh, but I think that, um, uh,
you could identify the data sets and measure both of these things.
And then, and then hopefully find a way to combine them
into a single real number, which I think- yeah.
And I think one of the ways you talked about in the,
in the videos as well as, right?
Does that make sense? Uh, yeah.
But I think- I think, uh, so the question is really, um, uh,
on what is it that satisfies a user need, right?
And, uh, and just one, one thing about,
uh, the straightforward way of rebalancing,
is that if you don't do this then your whole data set,
just has very few positive examples, right?
Um, and so if you throw away all the negative examples,
so that you cut down the number of negative examples until
you have exactly equal numbers of positives and negatives,
you've actually thrown away a lot of negative examples.
This makes sense? And so one,
one problem with the straightforward way of rebalancing,
is that, you know, in your audio clip,
in your test 10 second clip that we collected by running around Stanford,
um, you have one example of Robert turn on.
And so if you want exactly per,
perfectly balanced positive and negative,
it means that you're allowed to only clip out one negative example out of this.
You can say, that's negative and that's a positive.
And you can't clip out more negative examples from this, right?
So, so if you use,
uh- if you insist on a perfect rebalance,
you're actually throwing away a lot of negative examples that,
that could be helpful for the learning algorithm.
Great. [NOISE] Um, so all right.
[NOISE] So, um, you know,
a lot of the workflow of,
uh, building learning algorithms is,
um, uh, building learning algorithms feels more like debugging, right?
Because what happens in
a typical machine learning workflow is you implement something and it doesn't work.
So you figure out what is the problem,
so fix that, uh,
like rebalancing or reweighting or adding more ones.
And so that fixes the current problem.
And then after fixing the current problem, which,
which is the one we just solved, say,
you then come across a new problem and you have to solve that.
And you fix that problem,
you click somewhere else, another new problem.
So I find that, uh, the workflow of, um,
when I'm working on a machine learning project,
it often feels more like software debugging than software development, right?
Because you're often trying to figure out what doesn't work and you're trying to fix that.
And after you fix that problem,
then another bug surfaces and you squash that,
and you do that, and another, and you kind of keep doing that until the algorithm works.
So if I keep talking about,
you know, your algorithm doesn't work,
what do you do next, right?
That, that's kind of the theme of today's presentation.
But that, that is what the workflow- That is what
your day-to-day work of developing
a learning algorithm is usually like because it's like,
it doesn't work, and you fix it.
It still doesn't work, then you fix that,
and it still doesn't work, you fix it.
And you do that enough times until it works, right?
That, that is actually what often working
on a learning algorithm works- look, looks like.
All right. So let's say you fix that problem, um,
and you conclude, uh,
through doing error analysis,
that your algorithm is overfitting, right?
So you know, you've- you've added a lot more ones,
so the dataset is a little bit more balanced.
So let's just add a bunch of ones like I did on that previous board,
so let's just add a lot of ones here,
so the dataset isn't as unbalanced.
And um, [NOISE] let's see if- [NOISE],
um, right, okay, good.
Let's say that- sorry [NOISE] ,
see, too many pages of notes here.
Okay, good. So let's say that you find that it achieves now 98 percent
accuracy on training and 50 percent accuracy on the dev set, right?
So very large gap between your training and your dev set performance,
and so a clear sign of overfitting.
And so I think of one of the earlier questions,
someone talked about data augmentation,
and so we have this clear sign of overfitting,
this is a good time to consider data augmentation, right?
And then- and so let's say you go ahead and do data augmentation.
So for audio, this is how you could do data augmentation,
which is, um, collect a bunch of background audio.
You know, so I guess if you're trying to build a lab that might go into people's homes,
then you could go into your friends' homes and,
you know, with their permission, record, right?
What the background sound of their home looks like.
You know, maybe there are people talking in the background,
maybe the TV on in the background.
Well, whatever goes on in people- people's homes.
Um, and then, it turns out that if you take a, um, say,
a one second clip,
of Robert turn on, or RTO,
and you add that to a background clip,
then you can synthesize an audio clip of
what it sounds like in your friend's house if someone were
to suddenly pop up and say Robert turn on
against the background sound of your friend's house, right?
And- and it turns out that, um,
if you want to make the system robust,
so actually, for example,
have a- I know- I- I- I actually know someone that lives, unfortunately,
close near to a train station and so
their house actually has a lot of train station noise from the Caltrain.
And so what you can do to make your system more robust is
also take a clip of say train noise, right?
Like Caltrain noise,
and if you take that noise and take,
uh, in this case, let's say one-second,
one-second of a three-second clip of someone saying Robert turn
on and you synthesized that on top of the train in the background,
then what you end up with is a 10 second clip of someone saying Robert
turn on against the noisy train in the background type of noise.
All right. And so in order to do data augmentation or data synthesis,
you can take some one-second clips of people saying Robert turn on in
a quiet background and then take
some one second clip of people saying random words, right?
Let's say, you know, cardinal, right?
Since you're Stanford, and synthesize this against
the train noise background and then you would have, in this case,
you would have what sounds like train noise, train noise,
train noise, Robert turn on, train noise,
train noise, train noise, train noise, cardinal, train noise, and so on right?
And then you could generate the labels now as zeros there,
ones there and then zeros there, right?
Because if this is what it actually sounded like in a user's home,
then you want the lamp to turn on after Robert turn on but not after these random words.
So you can pick different random words.
Great. Um, so let's see.
Great.
So um, what I'd
like you to do is evaluate three different possible ways,
um, to collect noisy data, right?
To- to- to collect this type of background data, right?
Um, and so what I'd like you to do for the next question is let's say you and your team,
you know, have, ah, brainstormed.
Um, brainstormed a few different ways to collect  this type
of background noise data and let's say you've decided
that you would like to collect 10 hours of background noise data, right?
Okay? So I'm going to present to you three options.
One is um, you know,
run around Stanford and place microfilms around Stanford or in their friend's homes,
do this with consent and don't- don't, you know,
California as you- you- you're not supposed to-
don't record people without their knowledge and consent, right?
Second is download clips online.
It turns out if you go to YouTube there are these like 10 hour long clips of,
you know, rain noise or cars driving around.
So you actually- and again, if you do that,
find something that's Creative Commons and sort of appropriately licensed, right?
Another thing you could do is, ah,
use Mechanical Turk.
Amazon Mechanical Turk.
Where you can have people all around the world be paid,
you know, modest amounts of money to submit audio clips, right?
So for the next exercise what I want you to do because, um,
and I want that this exercise of discipline which is,
what I want you to do is, um,
I want you to estimate. Let's see.
What time is it now?
Okay, it's 12:30 PM right now.
What I want you to do is write down three numbers in
the next exercise to estimate if you were to do this,
you know, let's say you were to go do this right now, right?
By what time will you have finished if you were to do option one?
What time would you finish if you were to do option two?
What time would you finish if you were to do option three?
If your goal is to collect 10 hours of data through one of these mechanisms.
Does that make sense? So it's 12:30 PM now.
So what I'd like you to do is just write down three numbers.
First number is what time is it,
what time would it be by the time you collected 10 hours of data,
you know, from around Stanford.
What time would it be right- and if you could do this
in- so if you think you would do it by tonight,
then write 09:00 PM.
If you think it'll do, if you think it will take you one week,
that write the date one week from now,
right? Whatever it is.
But just write down three numbers of these three activities, okay?
Why don't you do this one relatively quickly?
Can people do this in like maybe a minute and a half?
All right, cool. This is interesting, um.
Yeah, whether people are, actually this is a surprisingly large variability.
I'll mention one thing that um, surprised me.
Um, I'll give you my own assessment.
I think that uh, you
know when I'm leading startup teams we tend to be very scrappy, right?
And so I think that um,
if the goal is to collect 10 hours of data,
if you have three friends who have a laptop you can collect
three hours of data per hour because you got three recordings going in parallel.
So if I were doing this with say two other friends you know,
I bet, I bet we could get this done by tonight, right?
Because if you need nine hours of data that's each person needs to collect
three hours of data and you run around Stanford and you keep the microphones running,
I bet, I bet I could get this done by 6:00 PM right maybe,
maybe even earlier I don't know.
Download clips online uh,
is actually, I don't know, it's actually an interesting one, maybe be about the same time.
Um, it turns out one tricky thing about downloading clips online is that um,
uh, I think a lot of the you,
the- there are people that um,
have trouble sleeping at night so they listen to highway noise or whatever.
And so there are these you know 20 hours of
highway clips highway noise on YouTube that you can find.
But I, I don't know how those clips are generated.
And I suspect a lot of them loop, right?
Meaning it's the same one hour played over and over.
So I actually think it's harder than, than,
than one like, yes they get 10 hours of
um [NOISE] non-repetitive data and it's one of those things you know,
if I take an hour of highway sound and loop
it you can't tell the difference because all highway sound sounds the same.
I just can't tell one minute of highway sound from another one
but if you have one hour of highway sound looped 10 times,
the learning algorithm will actually perform much less well
than if you have 10 hours of fresh highway sound.
So this I would actually have a harder time doing.
I think I've probably I,
I, I would prob- if I were doing this I,
because of these problems I would probably budget until sometime tomorrow, right?
May- may- maybe, maybe 9:00 PM or something. Maybe that's doable.
I'm not sure. Um, the one surprise
to me was some people thought they could do this by tonight.
Uh, I, a- again I've used Amazon Mechanical Turk is actually
a huge process to set up Amazon Mechanical Turk, get people on board.
Um, and especially to get them on microphone.
Uh, uh, I don't know if you implement something
on Flash that can speak in their web browser.
[NOISE] And then Flash isn't supported, it's,
it's, actually, it's actually not that easy to get a lot of
Turkers to do this and the global supply of [NOISE] Turkers is also unlimited.
So I would, if I were doing this I would
probably [NOISE] I don't know maybe a week or something, right?
Hard to say, I'm not sure um.
But so the specific opinion isn't that important but I want
you to go through this exercise because this is how um,
efficient startup teams should you know,
brainstorm a list of things and then you all figure out how long you
think it'll take to do these things and I think uh,
you can have a debate about how high quality the data is, I
think you can get very high quality data from this and from this.
Uh, [NOISE] I, I, I just don't trust a lot of those online audio sources.
Uh, but this is really fast and you can get pretty high-quality data.
I would probably do this to collect the background sound to get going, right?
But I think that part of their workflow I see of you know,
fast-moving teams is pretty much exactly what you did.
Which one, what is that the exercise of
brainstorming the lists of options and then really
estimating or what time can we get this done and then use that to pick an option, right?
Um, and then I wanna just mention one last thing uh,
which is that [NOISE] these differences matter, right?
Um, you know I've actually built, I've built a lot systems, built a lot of machine learning systems.
But um, oh and,
and I think by the way if you do everything we just
described and you'll see this later in a problem set.
Uh, you can actually with this set of
ideas pretty much this set of ideas that we just went through today.
You can actually build, build a,
build a pretty decent trigger word detection system
or wake registering word detection system.
In fact we'll oscillate through pretty much this in a later homework exercise.
But now you know when you get to that homework exercise when you do RNNs uh,
you know how you could come up with this sort of process yourself if,
if you didn't already know how to make these types of choices. Yeah, question
Just one question. Uh, I conduct my research [inaudible]
how my micro affect my result but
at the beginning it seems like it's not important like my micro [inaudible]
So when I download it,
it, my, what mess my result but what, what you have to think about it?
Yeah so my advice wha- [NOISE] ,
does the microphone affect your result, right?
[OVERLAPPING] My, my advice is would be to uh,
get something going quick and dirty and then develop a data set, right,
with the actual types of data you can develop on
your real microphone and then see if there is a problem and it may be er,
different microphones do have different characteristics.
And if it is a problem then go back and think about
how you collect data that's more representative how you
test. I wanna mention one more quick thing, you were handed
class surveys and wants to do something real quick which is um,
I wanna tell you why these things really matter which is um,
if this is uh, performance, right?
Uh, uh, let's say, actually let's say error.
And um, this is time, right?
And if this is today and you're the CEO of a startup remember that's,
that's what we're doing in this lesson.
And this is six months from now,
but this is 12 months from now.
Um, you know maybe if a competitor,
actually maybe, maybe I don't know.
[LAUGHTER] Maybe because we've talked about this so much in
this class maybe two of you in this class are  gonna build a startup and be a competitor.
Um, but over time most machine learning teams,
you know the error actually goes down over time as you work on problems,
very good and this is what I see in tons of practical projects.
You know, we work on project, improve the system,
and the error actually goes down over time as you work on
this over the next 12 months say but if you're really a CEO of
a startup doing this [NOISE] and it turns out that it's
the startups that have the discipline to constantly be the most efficient.
Um, don't do something that takes you two days.
If you can get a similar result in one day.
The difference is not that you're one day slower,
the difference is that you are 2x faster, right?
And then, then having that mindset if we take
this whole chart and compress it on the horizontal axis.
Um then you [NOISE] want to
be this startup that you know makes
the same amount of process in six months instead of 12 months, right?
And because uh, if you're able to do this then
your startup will actually perform much better in the marketplace.
Assuming your accuracy's important which it seems to be for wake word.
And so don't think of this as saving you a day here
and there think of this as making your team twice as fast.
And that's the difference between this level
of performance and that level of performance.
So that's why when I'm, you know building teams to
and executing these projects I tend to be pretty obsessive about uh,
making sure we're very efficient in exploring the options
and [NOISE] don't wait till tomorrow to collect data of
dubious quality when you have a better idea of collecting
data by today because the difference is not that you wasted 12 hours,
the difference you are twice as slow as a company, right?
So I think uh, so hopefully through this example on
your ongoing experiences throughout this course it can help
you continue to get better at this.
Right. Um, last thing we want to do [NOISE] was uh,
we're about halfway through the course and go ahead um,
we went to hand out a survey um,
an anonymous survey uh,
to get some feedback from you about this class.
And whenever we get these surveys uh,
we end up uh, uh,
thanks to previous generations of students' feedback.
We've already been gradually making class better.
So I think Ken and I actually read all of these questions ourselves and try to find
ways to take your feedback to improve the class so if you can take you know, five minutes um,
for this survey and you can hand it in just drop it off anonymously up here in front.
Uh, we're very grateful for your suggestions.
Okay? So um, I think if you haven't entered your ID yet uh,
you can still do so but uh, that's it for today.
So please fill out the survey and anonymously just
drop it off back in front then we'll wrap up. Okay, thank you.